hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to murder shifters now
somewhere out in the city there's a
murderer on the loose
you could take your shape the shape of
your butt he could take the shape of
your butt and then assume your role as
society as a butt but either way murder
shifters is another game that was made
for the Ludum get him
their game jam and it featured an
interesting game style that was wild
wolf or basically there's a murderer out
in the city and each time he murders he
shifts into the shape of the thing that
he murdered which is if he murdered your
butt he would be your butt see I'm not
wrong I'm just weird alright whatever
whatever let's go okay it's easier to
explain okay glutton gets bigger and
slower with every victim well that makes
it easy alright so there's a whole bunch
of different levels in the game I'm
assuming because I haven't played the
game yet but I'm just assuming from what
I don't know and you're the only
humanoid-looking douchebag in this
entire city and you're trying to find
this guy ah the Hunter has become the
hunted I did it I'm a hero
only one person hath deadly been dead so
basically you get this basically you
continue on with this until you get to
the different different enemies hunted
did I let him eat my giblets or did I
just let him eat my gun huh a man it
seems like there isn't a way to actually
save anyone or save everyone because at
least one person is gonna die no matter
what this is cool
alright where are you at speeder okay so
shape-shifting side effect
he gets faster each time to wave that
was pretty fast are you fast who's fast
who's got to go fast who's got to die
fast who did it who did it who did it I
see blood okay we got it all right it's
fine
why only shot two people I only killed
just as many people as the murderer
killed but that doesn't make me the
murder my special skill when I murder
people as I get less stars all right
let's go who's here huh what do you
wanna get shot by a GTO God killed two
people that will rest on my shoulders
with the duration of this all right
codename red murdering shied effect
turns redder leaves red instead of a
pink trail incredibly sturdy oh okay hey
don't spread out don't spread out I mean
spread out probably but I can't shoot as
many of you if you could spread out like
that all right we're yet we're yet huh
who wants to play oh he turned into me
oh he's incredibly sturdy hmm who's in
here who's in here who's in here who's
in here who's in here
oh where what happened I didn't see em
oh jeez this guy's tough all right I'll
get him though I'll get him
if I have to shoot
what the hell holy [ __ ] this guy's tough
all right maybe I should just start
shooting with reckless abandon that be a
bad idea well I can get this guy just
got to figure out where he is
oh where where where where I didn't see
oh god he's coming after me where's the
blood
I don't say oh the blood was all the way
down there all right so where's he who
did it goddamn it he's a mystery murder
who did it you coming after me oh oh
that was that was a civilian civilian Oh
who's coming after me oh you know what
too many civilians died I'm so bad I'm
so bad all right who wants some we're
yeah we're yeah we're damn it he comes
right for me where you know that one
with the three-star it's just oh man but
I got him okay so he's somewhere in here
and there's no walls to protect me who's
he gonna kill whoa who did it who did it
who did it who did it are you coming for
me whoa what the hell that guy yeah it's
okay I got him yes I did it not well but
I did it so that is murder shifters it's
a great concept I love this concept this
is great I don't know if it's a
completely original concept but I don't
know of any other games off the top of
my head that have something like this
it's really cool I like it
it's engaging it keeps you focused on it
like it's a lot of fun and for something
made in 48 hours it's pretty damn good
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you
in the next video